la priorité de la france est extrêmement
clair elle a été exprimée à plusieurs
reprises par la voix du président de la
république et du chef de notre
diplomatie jean marc ayrault
il faut impérativement arrêter les
massacres contre les populations qui
sont aujourd'hui dans les conditions
tragiques que vous avez indiquée prise
au piège d'alep
nous n'acceptons pas que les
bombardements et les combats puisse
atteindre un tel niveau de barbarie une
guerre totale oui une guerre totale a
été déclaré par le régime de bachar al
assad
avec le soutien de la russie contre son
propre peuple
la destruction délibérée d'hôpitaux de
d'établissements scolaires le ciblage
indiscriminé de population civile de
familles d'enfants constituent ce qu'il
faut appeler des crimes de guerre et
face à cela
vous avez eu raison de le soulever il y
à une urgence humanitaire
la russie qui est un grand pays au nom
de son histoire de sa culture de sa
place dans le monde doit enfin prendre
ses responsabilités de grande puissance
elle doit provoquer et respecter l'arrêt
complet des bombardements garantir un
accès humanitaire qui permettent
l'évacuation des populations civiles
comme l'annonçait d'ailleurs à la suite
de l'accord entre le régime et les
groupes armés qu'elle a coparrainé avec
la turquie
hier mais dont on voit aujourd'hui la
difficulté de la mise en oeuvre sur le
terrain il faut aussi que les crimes du
régime qui utilisent des armes chimiques
contre son peuple
crime mis à jour de manière indiscutable
par la mission d' enquête conjointe de
l'onu soit non seulement dénoncer mais
qu'il soit aussi c'est une question
d'honneur de morale devant l'humanité
poursuivis farouchement devant la
justice internationale
il ne peut pas y avoir monsieur le
député fort d'impunité pour les
criminels de guerre en syrie la
situation à l'ep est une véritable
injure faite à l'humanité est une raison
de mobilisation pour tous les humanistes
elle est inacceptable
et c'est la raison pour laquelle le
président de la république a reçu lundi
les représentants de l'opposition
modérée ainsi que les dirigeants des
organisations humanitaires qui
travaillent encore à alep où dans
d'autres villes assiégées
c'est pourquoi encore le ministre des
affaires étrangères a réuni le 10
décembre à paris les membres du groupe
des états affinitaire qui souhaite une
solution politique en syrie et c'est
pourquoi la france a demandé la tenue
d'une réunion d'urgence du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies hier nous
avons à cette occasion demandé
l'évacuation de la ville sous
observation internationale et en
présence des organisations humanitaires
et nous continuerons d'agir sans trêve
ni pause pour qu'une aide et une
protection immédiate et sans conditions
soient apportées aux habitants de la
partie est d'alep sans discrimination et
conformément au droit humanitaire
international ceux qui prétendent qu'il
n'y a pour la paix en syrie que le choix
entre bachar el-assad et des shs comète
monsieur le député une triple erreur une
erreur politique
une erreur stratégique mais surtout une
erreur morale